jetzt zum posterboy der deutschen
politik zur robert habeck deutschlands
beliebtester politiker angeblich laut
umfragen jetzt ist dieser mann den wir
seit jahren so kennen unter ganz
gewaltigem druck er hat die gasanlage
vermasselt fuß in seinem ministerium er
plötzlich der murks minister so heißt es
heute auch bei bild auf seite 2 es läuft
jetzt eine art countdown für ihn ein
ultimatum läuft die zeit weg um sein gas
umlagen gesetz zu reparieren so dass es
keine konzerne gibt die die umlage
abkassieren ohne sie zu brauchen also
ein gesetz dass endlich sicherstellt
dass wir nicht noch mehr zahlen müssen
als nötig bei der gas umlage robert
habeck heftig unter druck die die mit
ihm regieren die setzen ihm ein
ultimatum dazu gehört der spd chef lars
klingbeil schauen sie wie er den robert
habeck mittlerweile kritisiert er wirft
ihm tatsächlich in aller öffentlichkeit
handwerkliche fehler vor das sagt er in
der zeit also das ist eine derer die
eben mit robert habeck gemeinsame sache
machen in der regierung ganz ähnlich
dann ralf stegner spd
bundestagsabgeordnete auch eher harte
kritik an robert habeck und er setzt
ebenso ein ultimatum sagt die klausur in
meseberg das beginnt morgen
regierungsklausur das sei der richtige
ort und der richtige zeitpunkt um die
gasanlage neu zu verhandeln also da muss
es passieren sagt ralf stegner einen tag
hat er noch zeit der robert habeck und
die ex fdp generalsekretär in linda
teuteberg auch die knöpft sich h werk
vor mit diesen sätzen hier sie sagt
unglaublich dass verbraucher da unnötig
zahlen müssen bei der gas umlage also
die kritik für robert habeck massiv aus
den eigenen aus den ampel reihen
mittlerweile er wehrt sich am abend im
zdf und sagt dass
wir müssen sehen dass die unternehmen
die eigentlich keinen zugang zu dieser
umlage brauchen ihn auch nicht bekommen
und wie gesagt das ist ein problem wir
arbeiten an einer lösung und der staat
ist reingegangen wir haben ja zwei
unternehmen gazprom germania und juniper
mit milliardenbeträgen gestützt ist
reingegangen aber eine dauerhafte
finanzierung durch den staat ist eben
noch kein geschäftsmodell und deswegen
mussten wir diese umlage wie oder eben
die kunden dieser unternehmen allein im
mit den unternehmen lassen diese umlage
ist also ein solidaritäts mechanismus
das ist wohl so entschieden worden
deswegen muss man jetzt hat an dem
problem arbeiten und das tun wir auch
bei der gasanlage beziehungsweise bei
dem teil der gasanlage der unschön ist
nämlich das unternehmen sie ausnutzen
als trittbrettfahrer quasi um ebenfalls
abrechnungen zu stellen unternehmen dies
gar nicht nötig hätten wir werden dieses
problem lösen na dann das ist doch ein
versprechen er wird lösen sagt robert
habeck
[Musik]